TV tour vous le savez se mettre au vert
avec un reportage par jour dans ce JT
pour des initiatives remarquables en
faveur dans l'environnement je dis une
soirée spéciale dès 17h45 aujourd'hui
direction Lamotte-Beuvron là-bas un
méthaniseur alimenté par des habitants
des agriculteurs et les déchets du
centre équestre fédéral produit un gaz
vertueux elle aime chapelet s'était
rendu sur place il y a quelques mois
regardez
dans cette exploitation en plein cœur de
la Sologne Louis Xavier Delage élève
près de 700 moutons ces agneaux qui
grandissent en intérieur génère
évidemment du fumier auparavant il
s'entassaient dehors dans ce tas avant
d'être répandue sur les 160 hectares de
la propriété aujourd'hui il est
transporté dans des caissons étanches à
6 km de là dans l'unité de méthanisation
de la Motte Beuvron le fumier de ces
agneaux est notamment mélangé au crotin
du Parc équestre fédéral et au bout de
la station d'épuration toute proche le
biogaz issu de cette fermentation et
revendu à un opérateur privé quant à
notre agriculteur il récupère un résidu
appelé digesta qui s'avère être un très
bon engrais naturel et donc c'est très
riche en matière organique ça permet à
mon exploitation de pouvoir bien
bénéficier de déchets organiques qui
n'était à l'origine pas valorisé voire
gâcher ce qui permet de maintenir des de
matière organique
satisfaisant surtout dans nos sols de
Sologne sur lesquels parfois il est
difficile de maintenir des taux de
matières organiques assez bon 11
millions d'euros
en partir de terre cette unité de
méthanisation parmi les porteurs de
projets une quinzaine d'agriculteurs
comme Louis Xavier la Fédération
française d'équitation et la mairie de
la Motte-Beuvron 30 000 tonnes de
déchets sont traités ici chaque année il
génère en énergie l'équivalent de la
consommation annuelle de 1800 foyers
la formule rien ne se perd tout se
transforme qui est la formule de GrDF
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on prend des
intrants naturels qui soient agricoles
ou ménagers on en fait du biogaz qui est
pas un gaz fossile derrière le résidus
ça devient engrais et on capte le gaz à
effet de serre qui est le CH4 qui est un
des gaz les plus violents pour alimenter
quotidiennement se méthaniseur à la
mairie a également mis en place quatre
récupérateurs de biodéchets les cantines
et les particuliers sont donc incités à
apporter leur déchets alimentaires pour
qu'ils soient eux aussi valoriser